meantime also here at 11 a 22 year old
is charged with dui after a serious
crash in north las vegas thursday night
a one and four-year-old were hurt when
three cars crashed near cheyenne and
pecos julian valdivis was arrested
for that crash police say he was
speeding down pecos when another car
tried to turn and they hit both of the
children are still hospitalized tonight
and there really have been a growing
number of dui crashes here in the valley
so the question is what's being done to
stop it especially now that the dui
strike team is no longer exist orco mana
live at metro's traffic bureau tonight
with the answer for us orco
well denise the dui strike team was a
joint effort between metro police and
nevada highway patrol to stop impaired
drivers behind the wheel they would
often meet here at metro's traffic
bureau to celebrate their successes but
even with the team gone i've learned the
work continues
there's that constant void there it's
been nearly two years since misha
escobia lost her father marshall in a
dui crash near tropicana and rainbow her
mother who broke five ribs that day
still suffers the trauma that my family
went through is horrific and worse every
day is still a struggle that's why misha
is disheartened to hear the dui strike
team is gone i don't understand why it's
getting dismantled now that our numbers
are going up andrew bennett with the
nevada office of traffic safety says the
dui strike team disbanded because of
staffing at nhp but the work is not
ending the team itself at metro is
continuing it's just no longer
multi-jurisdictional the dui strike team
is credited with nearly 4 thousand
arrests since it began in october 2018 a
successful dui blitz happening as
recently as last month do you think it
will still be effective now without the
strike team i believe in the efforts
that we're doing that includes ramping
up the use of a dui processing van
starting october 1st that van will
actually be
out three nights a week so we're
tripling the efforts bennett says the
dui strike team could come back in the
future that's something misha wants to
see if there's even a chance that we can
prevent something from happening i think
it's a great service to the public
i reached out to metro police and nevada
highway patrol to learn their specific
plans but they were not available to
speak with us north las vegas police who
were actually never involved with the
dui strike team tell me that they plan
to do enforcement through regular
operations and that they also plan joint
intervention with other jurisdictions
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now